what's up rambley toes Rambo rouses
ramble rouses now that was so today
Friday let's get some some some stuff
out of the way if you listen to this on
Friday I'm in Santa Cruz I don't even
know why I'm plugging Santa Cruz it's
sold out
I'll be in San Luis Obispo Obispo Sunday
to 14th in Phoenix Monday and Tuesday
and copper blues
so yes San Luis Obispo Phoenix Monday
and Tuesday you get two tickets at
Hannibal Burres DICOM slash tour we're
gonna be on luminary now that's where
the podcast is going we're gonna be on
luminary exclusively go to get luminary
calm for more info but that's what's
happening officially on April 23rd Kevin
Bozeman is on this episode frequent
guest friend of the show friend in real
life he has his new album it's called
two-parent love it's available on all
that stuff all of the naps you know what
it is so what's on that and it's a good
Aang we recorded this one in January in
Chicago and there's always a good convo
with Bozeman he talks about suburban
life there's a he lives in the suburbs I
live in the city so there's a bit of a
clash there's a culture clash a bit
there I have some ideas about the suburb
he asks some thoughts about city life we
don't get into fisticuffs or anything
but it almost gets there it could have
gotten there it could have gotten there
maybe check the up
[Music]
with a special guest have a boat
[Music]
cover-up I wanna I don't wanna see ya
the whole time Oh dope yeah you know
I've done a couple like it it is it is
really fun so I'm glad there's no first
time having to guess do it oh man I
don't know why you don't require
everyone to go blindfold it just adds an
element it's a fun element and I think
it it makes you a better rapper because
you have less distractions clear thought
clearer thought yeah you just in your
head so you able to true advocate uh can
I share this among friends
absolutely everything now it again my
girlfriend was sleep with one of these
yeah every time I want to murder her
because why because the her comfort
level was just uncomfortable to me this
she covers up our eyes so she could just
cover up your eyes and sleep like that
and then not entrust it nothing's gonna
happen yeah I mean I so I just like I'm
never gonna murder her I mean I wish
didn't say never but I'm not gonna
murder her but God I'm wanna I want at
least playfully choke her
well I think you know isn't this with
these masts for to be choked no it's
nothing
you know my bad I've been doing it wrong
I mean you know everybody lives
different lives so I can't speak to
other people's use of I I when I was
flying back from Africa I used one and
it's just the the quality of sleep was
better so then I just started walking
around the house with it on just for fun
yeah and I say let's do a podcast and
then I feel like it helped my podcast
definitely my energy it's just kind of
just throw [ __ ] off and he just I
definitely was I was uh I was a better
rapper man
so I want I'm glad you uh willing to try
it out I embrace it so so this will make
me a better rapper rapper be it may drop
a baby what's great about this
Hey Ya Ya Ya cuz I'm blind and I create
give me some pits and a date yeah gimme
it with bacon and the grease come up on
homie in I'll say piece piece of pizza
Gerald named Lisa she's a big dope bass
frico I love her but she don't love me
that's why I dropped a two eternities
BAM nice amen
freestyle
that's definitely not a pocket in the
pocket in the pocket in the pocket
bet I love it I love it I would think I
would think they're being blindfolded I
would be able to hear you more crisp but
that clearly didn't I might not be
talking directly to the microphone now I
don't know if I'm talking directly into
microphone soon I think I said that I am
yeah yeah so man what's up fellas long
time no see okay be in it man I feel
like when we get together it's like we
get together and then we not we don't
see each other like you know we got
there be like bad we'll hang out how
long five four out of five weeks and
then it's just like oh man
do do what you do I'm gonna do what I do
and we'll connect yeah be like that
sometimes you know traveling traveling
comedians on the road etc etc you got
the new album just dropped yes sir to
parent loves man Haron love available
all streaming sites and available hard
copies - no not yet yeah not yet I'm
right usually for one I'm doing I'm
about to do a bunch of colleges right
and I'm not trying to sell albums to
college kids now think at that that cash
and plus I don't want to look at them
after the show and they don't want to
look at me so let's let's get I don't
comfortable in this out of the way so
when when I start going back to clubs
and stuff I think I'm gonna have some
sort of maybe a digital download maybe I
might make a hundred or two hundred
copies just just because but
use a vinyl ooh do some vinyl honey no
limited edition vinyl get it get about
it yeah honey a couple hundred on it
autograph them get some dope art yeah I
dig that man yeah
are you blind right now - can you see
yeah I can see Oh God cuz your vision
you want me to go blind - at some point
want me to at some point I do right now
right now let me find my way all right
let me find my way
so yeah doc my toupee love album is out
it's uh it's kind of like my fifth album
I'll call it in my fourth album because
I also did album strictly for Pandora
where it was just clean so I pulled off
like all my greatest hits of clean jokes
okay you ever do something like that we
just put something out just for like
just for like alternative hey man here's
something else that I can do for you if
you're the type of person that works
affect your day here's something that
where I eliminate those words and here
you go I thought about doing that but I
have it know a clean set we if we
wouldn't be just clean no it would be
whatever alternatively that you do like
you can just do real rap beats and just
you just like oh here's Hannibal and you
know yeah rap gibberish oh yeah and all
that other stuff that's what I do every
I was about to say every week we had
that consistent but every time we put
this out whenever that is when we put
this out we get that [ __ ] and we put it
out up load it put
[ __ ] hard drive and the Dropbox
[Music]
what's your morning routine duh my
morning routine
yeah it's is really
Metamucil okay right Metamucil I'm
finding Metamucil is the game changer
son when you get that that that fiber in
you and you can get that one nice [ __ ]
to start your day okay
unstoppable unstoppable and then I go to
the office which is a Starbucks and you
and I know how I roll with my coffee and
then I sit there and then try to create
create some content like I try to put an
hour to in a day even if that hour half
of it turns into figuring out who I'm a
gamble on who I'm a bet on but then then
I gotta get all my [ __ ] cuz when I'm
home
I gotta get all my [ __ ] done right away
because then my kids get home and then
then it's over and I'm just a glorified
uber driver all I do is just drive them
places over driver with wisdom well we
were driving with wisdom that they don't
listen to that's cold that's cold and
hurtful what's the what's the wisdom
that you try to repeat and you it's been
ignored
put the [ __ ] time in a gym doc I paid
so it ain't just like when you group
when we grew up
it was just like y'all go outside and
play and you went out and played and
worked on your game too
you know it got dark or whatever it's
streets became unsafe but now
everything's got to be organized so when
I my kids want to play hoops and
competitively I got a drop a thousand
dollars just for them to be in this AAU
League or whatever a thousand thousand
thousand dollars per kid just hoop four
seasons at occluding jerseys equipment
shoes that includes jersey equipment no
shoes
that includes jersey equipment and some
travel but not airplane flights when
they got to fly so all I'm saying is if
I gotta put this money in you I am now
treating basketball and soccer like
homework great I've invested too much
money so I have to mentally prepare to
have them question my knowledge because
they think that coz only played d3 I
really don't know [ __ ]
do they say that there you play that you
know some white wine eating even average
double figures come on now they don't
say that but they always just like Billy
they fill in a detention yeah you don't
want especially now my kid is taller
than me and he was ranked he's ranked
22nd prospect and a state Illinois for
sophomore so you can't tell him [ __ ] now
you can't tell him [ __ ] he yeah you
can't get up to 23 buddy he he came to
me went down the cars like that I feel
like I know what it takes this is after
games like I know where it takes I don't
think anyone's yes so he must have got
buck as this guy no he has 6 points and
3 rebounds 6 points and 3 rebounds they
get the W yeah they got the W plus six
points three rebounds and then the pop
dogs is saying what Dad I just I just
feel like I just all coming together me
and I think I'm just gonna be like it's
just hard for some anyone to stop me
and I was like he goes I didn't miss a
shot I go you only took three shots she
was three for three or six points it's
three rebounds three assists
no it's this that's this look he steals
oh yeah he got some steals okay he got
some steals and some blocks seasoned
defensively he's a monster
all right he's the opposite of James
Harden okay like hardened offensively is
my son
defensively okay so he can't like him a
little you know Travis Outlaw Reggie
Evans kind of stat like yeah now Reggie
Evans got boards
oh you Travis Outlaw is just a hustle do
make hustle plays make it hard to end
back he got a little Scottie Pippen
rookie here and I'm he got long arms
always making like when you make a pass
the passes always hire it because he's
he's putting so much pressure and he
gives the chance for his teammates to
get steals because he's making you make
a difficult pass that being said don't
[ __ ] tell me
unstoppable dog right that's a
hospitalization half his recent yeah
very recent he was uh riding shot I lost
sleep yeah I lost sleep on that
statement tank so what did you say cuz
you couldn't be harsh like you would so
a stranger but you know you can be okay
and you should be alright
I laughed and told him that he had six
point laughs like aa dog you had six
points
this is ridiculous conversation but he
stood by he's still buying what do you
have the next game
thirteen or something like that since he
said that he said that he actually been
all about to it but like you showing me
up that way shooting threes now I okay
cool so he you know we we stray suburbs
so we went to the we went to the hood
and played a Farragut and Farragut guys
in a tire yeah they just they was just
little and they was all strong he's all
strong all they do is lift and run
that's what Farragut does not I'm could
shoot but you it was hard getting it's
all going to the bucket that is going to
the rack finishing screaming screaming
like me let's go be like this all day
and the kids in the suburbs is like what
the all day all day
if you mean yeah and yeah so that's
their only loss of the season though so
far they are bomber but what you gonna
do I still you know I just want to
Division one athletes is that I asking
too much it's not I mean it's ambitious
you should be if I'm paying if I'm
paying a thousand dollars a year to put
them to hoop so this is kind of uh in
your mind this is like a bet where the
the payoff is free college tuition yes
yeah it's an investment it's an
investment
I'll because it is a term investment
it's a midterm investment okay that's
fair right yeah but look 810 thousand
dollars now and then paying off twenty
five thirty thousand dollars a year for
four years later absolutely easily I do
the Rd might be low might be low prime
money slow right problem probably is low
well how old is the oldest one right
sixteen he's just he's a sophomore and
are they are they scouting him yet I'm
sure people have looked at them because
once they go to AAU and he plays in a
these tournaments when we fly to Texas
and Minnesota and [ __ ] like well huh
I have all of that you better be dope
all right so what do you think you can
do as a as a parent and a motivator
what can you step up and how can we help
you I have a couple ideas I want to hear
yours first what I can do to make my
kids better become Division one athletes
yeah cuz it sounds like they're not
listening to the advice so I already did
some you know I know what I did I do
I took their video games from one yeah
took it from and they was like we didn't
do anything wrong I was like you did not
do anything wrong but I don't like who
you guys are as people right now all
right so today was like we don't
understand I go you will understand I
was like once you guys once you guys
don't have video games and you sitting
around and I'm letting them keep their
phones temporarily because all they
doing right now is just going and
watching videos I show them their phone
I'm about to take that problem too or
just restrict their times and so it's
just gonna force them to go and who go
hoop whatever if you want me to go with
you I will go I will go a rebound when
I'm at the crib let's go let's go so
that's what I did I took their video
games from okay and when I took their
videos like I let them keep everything
set up but I just took the the core to
plug into the
outlet right I'm gonna walk around with
video game boxes and I'm going through
my crib trying to find video games I
just took the cord of course I can just
pack in my suitcase it's no biggie
yeah that's simple what my suggestion
all right
some you create some type of like
scared-straight situation with a player
that had the talent but didn't work hard
enough and didn't make it to college
when he could have now we can find
somebody to actually do that or just
somebody else there's this tall and
older and they say you know my dad used
to try to get me too but then and I had
the opportunity and then I didn't go to
college so look at me and then you could
do some crack in front of y'all crack
alright
faint crack if a crack stunt crack stunt
track yeah I saw hire an actor an actor
to play a guy who had who had many
potential and I could Photoshop up like
some some articles from his high school
years yeah it's a show like when he was
kind of ballin but didn't take it to the
next level yeah and even something
showing his ascendance and then like I
could do an article too
you're like oh so much unfulfilled
potential and you want to be this it's
elaborate but like we're talking about
the dollar think big when you deal with
these type of situations so I'm just
here to help
dude I like that idea I like the I like
to be honest I like the evil that's
behind it like is very disingenuous and
which is what you need to raise a kid
sometimes you got to be disingenuous but
you know there is that story out there
about that who's that one kid Lenny
somebody did you see that documentary
where he was like the number one player
and high school and then he played
against LeBron who was like number
to player and highschool and LaRon
dominated them and hit a game-winning
shot over and then Lenny end up just
falling apart and then he was like when
LeBron hit that shot over me my career
was over and they followed him the whole
time and they show him like you know
he's like 33 now 30 34 years old that
sitting around living in a trailer home
till he broke down just mentally and
high school [ __ ] to [ __ ] up out of
hot [ __ ] up his senior year in high
school
[ __ ] up a senior in high school tried
to go to college went straight to the
pros didn't get drafted in NBA played
overseas for a minute got no clock
played and the CBA was a bust and just
out of the league he probably made a
total of less than a hundred thousand
dollars and he was the number one
prospect coming in he was a year ahead
of LeBron and all the kids looked us on
this video of Carmelo
Joakim Noah all of them like dude this
was the dude I think Joakim Noah
produced the documentary about this kid
and so it's out there there's their
stories of people letting it all go the
prime destroy believe the prime destroy
my cuz
I could have been a contender now I just
sit out on outskirts paint it all the
fancy feels with you guys don't see
right now is the tears coming down
through this this mask I'm aware you
know tearing up a sad story i I was at a
Bulls game a couple months ago yeah
and Joakim was at that game yeah before
he signed with yeah he was chilling at
the game you know he put the camera on
him and uh great from loving whatever
and so they were showing in the suite
they were showing after the Bulls game
the Timberwolves were in a game that was
close
and you know Timberwolves at the time a
coach by former Bulls coach times if
they would oh yeah yeah you know Derrick
Rose Taj Gibson and somebody else I
think from the Bulls right from the old
bulls I Luol Deng Luol Deng mm-hmm
and so uh Joakim was really watching
intently he was watching that that game
and actively rooting for them and I said
eh you gonna go you gonna go over there
too and he didn't appreciate it
uh he was offended you know I don't know
if he was offended but he he kind of he
brushed it off and I thought it was a
fair question for a free agent who has
limited options yeah um I didn't I
wasn't trying to I wasn't trying to like
be like hey I didn't it wasn't like I
said you know you're gonna go to play in
Canada so I'm like yeah you gonna play
for yo coach and you're with your
friends right you gonna play for the
Yugoslavian national team because that
would be offensive guy cuz any half
Yugoslavian is dead
Yannick Noah Yannick Noah though I want
to say eat from somewhere heat from
somewhere he's a famous athlete who's
new Yannick Noah was a was the tennis
player was his French French Yugoslavia
in French - Wow is this why I fold it to
correct me about it don't matter
yeah I mean that's you know this ain't
no trivia show hey don't correct me
don't correct me it's not necessary for
you to correct me about the travelens of
no world flow uh come on y'all let's
grow up apart or together
it don't matter this shitty weather now
climb it alright here's my rebuttal cuz
oh we have to can't beat spreading this
false info Yugoslavia is different from
France man ain't no offense but damn
they not even close
you didn't even say Belgium or Germany
Yugoslavia the same Vlade Divac way from
I don't even know they just oh I can fit
he would be shooting the three and I
said what's up at the all-star game he
didn't look at me I said
paisa you ain't even got a ring what the
[ __ ] is you even thinking you wanna
fight yo what if I thought somebody that
was seven foot tall would I have a great
chance or would I lose it all at the
Barclay center get beat up in the face
denied neck swept them like sub-zero
from that one game that was made by the
company Midway Mortal Kombat is what
they call it that's what they say dude
that's pretty good man whoa oh yeah uh I
gotta just a man is mind altering man
this really read yeah absolutely
everything
these these are he's he's a tight - yeah
I was smashing my eyeballs back sure
there's no way I'm glad to see - you
guys are actually here I woke up just
the TV screens easier I mean that could
be outro music
yeah alright so what's up what's up
that's going on let's talk about this
album some more 800 guerrilla Andrew
pound gorilla produced it is recorded in
my home club Madison comedy club home
state yeah need to record it this summer
yeah I recorded uh yeah in the summer it
was just some material that I was just
you know I originally I record it but a
summer before that yeah you record
something you sit on it and then the
more you sit on it the more you like
I could do this better right and he's
just like and I could have dropped that
last one easily and I've been just fine
but I was just like I can do this better
and I just like like I just have more
[ __ ] to say about being a parent and you
know and living in the burbs growing up
I grew up on a Southside Chicago and I'm
in the western suburbs not not like that
suburbs that treat people like [ __ ] but
like I live in a suburb that's next to
the suburbs to treat people like [ __ ]
which suburb is the one that treat
people like [ __ ] hensdale hensdale is
where all the loot is like every would
like the everybody got big fat ass
houses and donors like Downers Grove are
the people that's the Vice President to
the people and that's the president ends
there all right and it's just like a
real different it's just a real
differences yeah yeah it's it's great
it's just like I want to give like I
just got jokes about it just that
perspective of growing up in the suburbs
and not many now more black people
starting to come out cuz you know you
got her everybody running rightfully
from the city except for Hannibal who
embraces his culture like this I'm a
city boy city boy city boy city boy City
for came the burbs yes you can
city boy city board uh City board city
boy keeping my over priced taxes and all
the contestant give me that pollution
give me that stress
give me those pockets acres give me that
mess I'm a city boy city boy give me all
that [ __ ] give me walk around give me
all of it city boy city boy hell yeah
I'm a city boy ah I'm a city boy
no birds won't stops city boy cops city
boy gonna get a damn sandwich city boy
can't really have a say boy that's what
I do I'm a city boy give me all had no
Oh city boy is all out of control so
yeah I'm out about it yeah of course yes
my album coming out and it's and it's
burps I also talked about being in the
city I talked about all the [ __ ] like I
like to push the envelope right I feel
like that's my best comedy it's seeing
like what I can get away with hmm and
and I feel like that's I feel really
good about this album yeah sometimes you
put something out you're like oh yeah
but this is this one I stand behind I
stab me I'll actually my last my last
three my first one does not stand up we
hired like a production team yep yeah so
how many people was that like with the
800-pound gorillas that basically worked
through just one or two guys but they
got you know they got a crew they're not
a big big group they're probably 10 deep
or whatever but that's still a pretty
book that's that's still a mandate yeah
great marketing they do all of that
stuff you you know you and I have had
several conversations when it comes to
marketing social media I got to be top
three worst mm-hmm like I'm horrible at
it like I'm I'm bad at it I've always
hidden Hannibal up and he's just like
yeah you doing this wrong yeah but now I
got people I know I'm doing it wrong so
I got people looking out for me exactly
just the one thing where you would post
up oh I was on this this show right
oh you posted up on Instagram I was on
this daytime show and it just be a
picture of me and there he'll be like we
made see the video Bo's going to WS
energy I wanna watch them do it I can't
be pasted the copy and paste then I get
it I totally get it
just I just found a
and I'm still trying to I'm still
learning but it's just really as easy
you could make things for people just
that's really it just make it easy for
me that we were talking about that show
I was at and Oklahoma City hmm at the
loony bin where there's woman they were
kicking out five women before I was
going on stage it was kicking out five
women and I was on stage and one of the
women came storming back in and sat down
with security Hannah and they tried to
grab her to remove her and she started
screaming during my set and then hops
down cross under the table and kicking
all of the security as they trying to
drag her out look and then he was like
yo man if that video is out there that's
three million views in three hours
there's no way that and she's there not
a nerd
her kids I like mom mom you're
embarrassing those mom right
yeah and that's just so that's just a
golden moment loss that only you know
200 people will be able to recall and be
like you know I was there that night and
they probably change to 400 cause you
know people like and if not even for the
internet even just even for your group
of friends and yeah I've been trying to
do that more to just even if I know that
I'm doing a [ __ ] that I'm doing just
have this show filmed just in case
that's the case you can always and it's
the easy delete yeah there's just a
regular show delete it gone right back
record it again it's not like you got to
buy all these tapes and save them on now
you got your set you run your set you
record it do you review your sets right
away or only when I'm creating new
content and even then it's only
if I say something they got a better
response than I thought or worst
response than I thought then I want to
listen and figure out why I got that
response but I mean I hate listening to
myself yeah it seems like that's
unanimous with most comics there's just
like I don't like listening to my set
back yeah yeah I don't yeah I don't
really like it that much
I'm trying I'm getting better at it I've
actually gotten better
recently at listening to these because
it's certain parts that little weird
sound bites that and things that I like
to cut and use or whatever so yes mom is
just to get over in just you know cuz
nobody is gonna wanna you know like you
do that [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] out when I was landing at my mother
I was pulling out all the cops I was
like hey I gotta sleep here overnight
I really forced that right for sure I'll
take over this rap starting right now
listen to myself
don't make me I don't wanna listen to
myself that's not healthy
healthy makes me wealthy and I'm
stealthy I sneak into your creepy
maybe they make pineapple Snapple peach
iced tea you will feel me some wealthy
and I'm healthy but don't make me listen
to
[Music]
all right yo you said push the envelope
earlier
yeah and I got me thinking where did
that saying come from is that push the
envelope across the table or is it push
the envelope into something that's
already stuffed with a bunch of other
envelopes and other objects or is it
like push the envelope putting stuff
stuffing in the envelope yeah I think
it's it's uh it's stuff in the envelope
and there's already too much stuff and
the envelope and you're still like now
I'm gonna push this envelope you like no
we can't take any more and you're like
now no afford stamps no four envelopes
you can't I mean like these Millennials
you think they even you think they ever
use an envelope seriously I think
anybody probably use an envelope now I'm
like in the late nineties probably don't
you know [ __ ] envelope so push the
envelope is a old-school thing envelopes
used to be really important in the
community so you like don't push the
envelope people like oh [ __ ] this all my
fault I was getting mad when I go to
Walgreens that's what I tell them to put
the condoms in put these condoms you
guys ever buy weed and it came in a
manila envelope uh like a like a smaller
one yeah like a small like brown manila
envelope a couple times yeah I just love
that those small manila envelopes
there's always a key in it that's what I
get yeah yeah slanging with hello tiny
my envelopes yeah someone that stamps on
them and [ __ ] because it said to
differentiate the type of weed it was
the strain no this is bad
there's no such thing as strangers just
we yeah like you'd drive down the block
you knew what a spot was and you just
say whedon and then you pull over and
then some will run out how many three
four whatever and then they'll just
throw a bunch of envelopes into the car
and you drive off anybody wins so my my
definition then will be pushing the
envelope is saying things that makes
people uncomfortable and seeing if I can
still get quality laughs out of it okay
okay right like talking about maybe
taboo subjects [ __ ] that people don't
want to hear about you know I could one
of my bits is about is about leaving my
kids so they can be better basketball
player [ __ ] like that like you know I'm
leaving my kids I mean oh that's not
mine tonight both of them know not all
three of them all three of them but yeah
but like just talking about [ __ ] like
marriage politics all the stuff that is
just like yo cuz you know cuz we a look
at you now like oh you and your forties
you're not married
what are you doing wrong - [ __ ] you mean
what am I doing wrong I'm doing it right
everybody else is doing it wrong how
many you have real talk real talk real
talk how many happy married couples do
you guys truly know happily married will
you look at them you like oh [ __ ] what's
they secret they killing it go John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen you know that
though hmm do you know that yeah I feel
I feel the energy through Instagram well
cookbook hmm you feel the energy through
a cookbook
yeah Martha Stewart and Snoop Dogg yeah
Stephen a Smith and Max Kellerman true I
don't think I'm not sure they get you
today the best of friends what you can
name a [ __ ] ton of people there's not
happily married oh right yeah you just
start it just nuts coming off you like
oh [ __ ] there's not much force rates are
like astronomical well mm-hmm but those
are just the people who have balls to
break it all right what about the people
you know so just what are you worried
about helping them be alone
[Music]
only pieces away
[Music]
No whoa that uh that alone situation
might be the best rhyme of the day for
sure you made that I thought you don't
go
I thought you zone so many other places
but you may sit you a show I can connect
with a lone doubt that's impressive man
man yeah make it happen you push the
table here's the envelope look in there
there's a gift for you
open it up yep you like that you're
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome what you have podcasts yeah man
you know it's the ball hawk podcast
still cranking it out like a lunatic I
don't have the near the dope [ __ ] y'all
do I don't have gas I've had I couldn't
three guys my entire you Chad Daniels
and Mike North oh damn all I do is when
I'm out I'm at the mercy of everyone
else hey man you in town you got to go
on this TV station and promote the show
yeah going this radio station promote
the show and they always controlling the
narrative always that's why you gotta
bring a person with you everywhere we
mean like when you go to those spots I
mean they control the narrative on that
show would you film that - yeah right
that's right I need to have a person
just that we just film and record
everything but this podcast allows me to
get the [ __ ] off of my chest whatever it
is I want to talk about and I
the answer right Danny by ice why it's
called the ball hog podcast because I
just don't I just don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
around with gas unless they like my boys
because it's like bill birnes where you
just kind of ran things yeah but even
right hit rants but even he still brings
in he still brings in I think he still
brings in some guy Hagelin right he has
neon his wife sometimes and then he's
had a couple people but it's mostly
mostly him right yeah that's some [ __ ]
to say like I went so I just been
throwing it out there just pushing it
and I'm not sure if I believe this but I
say James Harden is the best player in
the NBA let's discuss people are just so
fired up but the more people get fired
up like the more the all their arguments
are poor which is now making me actually
believe that James Hart it might be the
best player in the NBA because the
arguments are so poor like I want I
might just say one thing I'm like oh
[ __ ] like yeah you're right
he's not the best but I haven't heard it
yet what's your purse but I want to hear
your perspective on that why you think
or why you say for what he's done yeah
for what he's done but what's around him
all right so he's been he's front runner
MVP this year I think we can all agree
with that yeah he's great he's scoring a
lot of points
so he's MVP to last year he was
runner-up the year before and then a
runner up two years prior to that and
then he's been to two Western Conference
Finals he beats a three games off for
Golden State last year which is twice as
many as LeBron one from Golden State and
two years combined great they got swept
by Golden State and they won one game
about Golden State right LeBron who's
arguably and that team is built around
LeBron he's only had one certified do
for that whole run and that's Chris Paul
everybody else's best players Ben Eric
[ __ ] Gordon or Clint capela not bad
dudes at all but not great so at some
point we're gonna say yo man just do and
now he's just running all of his players
hurt and he's just like well I'm just
gonna score 50 a game and
try to stop me it's pretty impressive
and everybody says you don't play D
which I agree but if somebody light him
up for 30 and he puts 60 on them that's
plus 30 homes houses defense it's
horrible it's horrible
so that how can you say that he's the
best if he doesn't move doesn't matter
it's just like when when if I say shacks
unstoppable and you go he can't hit free
throws but he's making it up if you go
if you go 16 for 23 from the field and 4
for 12 from the free-throw line
it don't matter he still went 16 for 23
you couldn't hide bad defensive players
last year Houston was one of the top
three defensive players in the league
and it's in the league their team
defense and heart and he put hard and
play bad defense so you can hide you've
historically hit [ __ ] that
can't play defense yeah you just farted
right yeah have them on somebody else I
have the bird right bird and then you
have a shot blocker somebody you can
drive the bird bad defensive play of
magic bad defensive player there's been
so many dirk nowitzki bad defensive
player all won championships so telling
me he a bad defensive player ain't you
can hide that but you can't hide is that
[ __ ] coming at you and bout to
drop 50 on you so okay nice Andy look
you should never say LeBrons not the
best he's earned that but you can't take
away what hardens done and nobody's made
a compelling argument why shoot that's
all I'm saying
that's the [ __ ] I talk about my podcast
I'm trying to get Hannibal come out and
do this suburban show yeah these
suburban mumsy soccer mom why won't you
do a show
[Music]
we I got it out of work can you know I
can't my license I can't go out there to
die Stroeve I got beef out there
I can't got beat on the streets at
venues you know that's a union venue man
I can't even go there I heard the
teachers on strike I can't cross the
picket line doubt they strike it man you
know I just it's a taxi man you know I
got some I got beef with one of the
comics on the show dog man you know that
venue I heard had asbestos tile I can't
oh man it's just real any mole in that
green room that mo I'm alert man last
time I was there the carpet kind of it
just [ __ ] with my asthma you know what
I'm saying man that's a lot that's a lot
going on man and I heard it's like but
if you show up dog you know what you'd
be doing to be pushing the envelope the
envelope showing that you know a bestest
ain't gonna stop you like just cuz you
got beef with a comic you know your
license is shaky yes my shoes over there
and we're good for that that path to the
stage door in the green room right shoes
be messing up right that's I'm put you
right in the front row so hop on oh man
we're not gonna front row so just
nervous and just I just can't and I
usually mess myself when I'm in front
row especially if somebody does kraut
work or if they don't do no crowd work
at all what if what if every joke II say
I made sure the Glitter shut out oh the
glitter that get in my eyes and I can't
reverse the effects of my LASIK yeah
that's how they not get that you
probably shouldn't come in yeah man I I
mean that glitter and where's your LASIK
like that that's I wish I could but you
know
I'm a city boy going out in the world
was I come to the show of a cities boy
who burns ain't for me ain't go no
reason all impart no down as Kronos in
still no Schomburg no deerfield no Evan
still no Winnetka no River always no
apart
no Ferrentino Parowan no no no no no no
no William chin able to know Elgin no
Beauty no lumbar no rose
we lay no Country Club no Juliet no no
Santa ha no
can you met fantail
no bride whew no Harvey that's not what
I do
no suburbs no suburbs Oh
no scope the spine
[Music]
that's where I won't be Oh
Naperville no Naperville
that's where I will the opposite of will
be Westmont no West but no West but I'd
rather shoot myself in the chest money
[Music]
no carry pinky no kinky it ain't for me
thankfully rain-free no Frankford no no
Frankfurt I've heard it's like for
everybody's nose that's how it goes I'm
there any sick Cabo suburbs Villa Park
the whole park net during the light or a
turnip dark I'm that I'm fair
Oh
belated xeric no Lake Zurich oh it makes
me
[Music]
oh my balls you see me there in st. Roch
Norfolk ah Go Go no Chicago
no Chicago know what Chicago no eat
Chicago it's not oh it's a night go
holla tonight that tonight they wanna
holla tonight say you wanna fight if not
even if I call balls game on that water
Harlem Nights as mad there's not a sane
gurney no walkie
know what to think but I'll go to
Milwaukee alright yeah that makes sense
my walk is dope
yeah that was a great show we did there
was pretty dope yeah right
yeah Milwaukee the the theater and that
the different floors in the theater we
had two different rooms we all had like
our own floor and then we had the party
room yeah a lot of fans up at laws that
the Pabst Theater uh that was Riverside
oh it's all five paps though you are
yeah a lot of fans a lot of family in
Milwaukee yeah you know uncles and
cousins and aunts that green room that
comes through they come through their
games okay the big a spread and then
video data NBA Jam arcade in there yeah
they had a fridge just stock with beer
it's like the best green room that we I
think have oh I [ __ ] with the hockey we
were going I enjoy families there but it
is it sort of stresses me out and then
sometimes I always goodbye just got a
bounce though yeah I just feel like an
idiot I don't just feel like y'all have
a good time I appreciate y'all being
here thank you so much for your support
it was good to see y'all but I gotta go
I see all that in my head actually say
to goodbye yeah I got that I got that
tonight with the this kind of I like
necessarily family but all my neighbors
are coming yeah that's hard like people
you live next to an economy Compton or
did they buy ticking ah they got about
ticket it's a fundraiser
oh okay Dee is there a black club or
homeowners association and are you a
part I don't know do you have some type
of lead
[ __ ] position lot club president but I'm
president most comedic resident ever
come through if you want to talk to me
about changing yo house can we change
your house out here we've got some
uniform [ __ ] going on you better run
that [ __ ] by here I'm Bozeman I run the
block better right you'll [ __ ] better
mow your lawn break that lead
[ __ ] what's going on this is
Bozeman black I'm on that [ __ ] what up
[ __ ] better come through with
the vote month brother you know is me
and I'm in here for four years both both
men running a block up in the burbs
[ __ ] you to know the bird I'm
gonna keep these property tax down you
hurt my brother you better say to work
Oh show campaign song I like it yeah I
like it
sure if I'll have that campaign so I ran
just to just made up some [ __ ] I would
have just found something to run forward
that song
I love I would love that power just to
knock on the door hey what's going on
mow your [ __ ] long and goddamn
bushes embarrassing me man yeah shitty
on the soccer team
tell the pass the ball more yeah I got
some tips on your parenting too right
I guess right Nicks I saw on YouTube
teach your kid how to do what it do you
want me to raise your kid cuz I've been
looking out the window and see what you
did you're like here is trash minds I
don't your kid is gonna be one of those
wack folks that people hate all up in
the stove with some pennies in the back
trying to pay for some Oh mother
get your kid you can get ahead of this
problem why you headed mom brother are
you seeing this [ __ ] cuz my eyes on it
I'm trying to save you from this problem
this [ __ ] is gonna be all on your brain
you call me like I said I listen to him
listen listen to him back there but if
you don't your kid gonna be robbing my
kid and that's what I don't want mother
I'm out to move to the next bird if yo
kid act all [ __ ] dirt that's pushing
the envelope too far hey man listen down
I don't give a [ __ ] about the envelope I
grab the envelope and get it back got
the diced watermelon from the store up
in my hand
hell yeah I'm a bit [ __ ] hos me
guess next we get peels there's some
water wool soap I'd mother I'm just
making up words and bending them some s
what I want to say know what's crazy
about this is that he wrapped so much
day he doesn't even know how to just
talk [ __ ] I will tell you what I'm doing
tonight is go feel right okay all right
what they won't you know being up the
bar man my father be don't
that's hey you know I spit that [ __ ] cuz
I Spit this [ __ ] like a peddler dear
mother [ __ ] online make the remix so
that's why I Spit Tony trim on the drums
and I get that [ __ ] what they want but I
cannot
cuz I'm sitting down it was right here
and he'll block me like blaow but I
could but it's it would be a disaster
went to college for four years did to
stay around for the master cuz I didn't
even get a goddamn bachelor's got about
90 credit hours that [ __ ] don't count
for [ __ ] that's about 3/4 a degree my
[ __ ] act like I do sit there
I got a few classes was hanging out with
people that got degrees downtown for
napping [ __ ] was right yeah got
degrees you [ __ ] a Saluki no come on
make some noise who needs a full degree
who needs a full degree need no full
degree got 90 credit hours that's about
3/4 give me enough power I can change a
tire
you know I can't but I can call it
triple-a to come through if the tide
flat on my rental car I'll leave that
[ __ ] and you'll get it and then you
charge me I can test that [ __ ] and I'll
get on the phone and use my white voice
like sorry to bother you you know it
what's going on
well what's up that [ __ ] ain't a good
use of my time
you said you write but I like are you a
customer service cuz I just practice and
I rap and then they get all nervous and
they just get the manager without me
even requested and I said yeah of course
this is [ __ ] blessing I'm
snapping and I don't even care about
that [ __ ] I'm just on the phone wasting
time and living that [ __ ] I may be like
why you wasting time I'm like I don't
even know I just had some time to waste
I was in the doctor's appointment and
they was having say they was wasting my
time and I had to take yours what's up
but that went up and Nick got the blood
work came back she said it was all good
I said yeah no syphilis and chlamydia I
said damn back at it cuz I take and I
buy out this preemptively I was sick
with something and it killed the dick
disease
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]